Despite the success that you're having,
and you're getting more
and more well-known,
that you still get
mistaken for other actors.
Is that right?
Yeah, yeah I do.
Chelsea Peretti is someone
people always think I am,
on Brooklyn Nine-Nine, and Kristen Schaal.
And I also get DJ Qualls all the time.
[Conan] What?
(audience laughs)
Just like everyday.
We have pictures of
some of these people up
that you get mistaken for.
You don't look like,
there's you on the top left,
you don't look like, you
know, that's not right.
[Lauren] Oh yeah, the
girl from Spider Man,
Regina Topa, yeah.
But people think I'm, I mean
they don't think I'm him,
but they write to me everyday and tell me
that we're siblings or something.
He's great, I just, I like to be myself.
(laughs)
You're so much taller in-person.
Do you get that a lot from people?
Yeah, people are really surprised.
They think I'm gonna be tiny.
Yeah, people that see you
on Orange is the New Black,
and they think, okay, I get that too.
Anywhere I go places, people think,
"Okay, I thought you might be kinda tall,
"but not that tall", and I was surprised,
I finally get to say it to someone else.
You are so much taller than I thought.
Yeah, you too.
(audience laughs)
You turned it back on me.
The whole point.
I think you both look like DJ Qualls.
So there.
You got us.